Yes Mother of God I am The King nice
hello ever oh sorry
well sorry now you're just being naughty
I won't say anything oh I thought Bonnie
had left I was like oh no now we gather
wander around and die seriously no Jesus
[ __ ] this is kind of actually I'm gonna
go out there no no oh okay that's a bad
idea he's to the right [ __ ] I'm gonna
stop this my heart can't take it oh I
got this I got this oh here we go you
ready you ready you ready player huh
yeah oh my god Oh mark no that one
actually hits their face though good
yeah look where we win [ __ ] all the time
I don't care about that but I got you I
got you I got you woo all those in favor
of hangin bill ah all those opposed nay
the eyes happen
the border closes pull the sleeve up to
expose his wounded
is your friends dead bed
what kiss his face no that's disgusting
it's what the book says to do we did
like 5,000 things from the book okay
okay could we like eat part of him oh oh
I'm just trying to help and that's when
I collapsed my nemesis's lungs and
crushed his pelvis into his bladder and
then I sucked his dick
what another round of ale for my people
and I'll do me we won't do each other
probably I was a good poem
yeah [ __ ]
ah alright guys so this is super
exciting let's get started whoa hmm look
at this it's actually a bit Asian huh I
think all you got to do to get started
is say ok Google hello hey how's it
going oh oops my mistake what you don't
know a damn thing about me Barry let me
just point out and also rock the [ __ ] on
a piece of a puzzle let me say put in a
picture
trust know I'm Freddie I'm the leader
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
hey I I don't know a picture that we got
oh yeah
this is hard to walk with I just wasn't
on it oh these things are impossible to
walk
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye